and I I really think I was trying to
think of a similar equivalent of a woman
going to a club and I was thinking maybe
a man on a dating app but even that
isn't the same
um because again you're putting a girl
in a situation where men like you're
basically saying go to this club where
50 men are gonna try to sleep with you
at the same time why do women feel
entitled to acting the same way in a
relationship as you do single and it's
interesting because we expect men to
change when they're single like I don't
think most women want their guy going to
a strip club they don't want their guy
you know going on boys trips but we
expect to be able to go to a club like
my question is if this is a woman you
want to be a wife and a mother why does
she want to be in the club while dating
you